hi ich hätte gerne einmal 20er Nuggets
mit süß-sauer Soße bitte
ein bisschen mehr als 20 geworden
Chicken McNuggets ich weiß ehrlich
gesagt gar nicht wie viele ich in meinem
Leben schon gegessen habe ein ständiger
Begleiter bei Autofahrten bei Tagen an
dem man keine Lust hat zu kochen es ist
einfach ein Klassiker
die schmecken immer wieder gleich die
riechen immer wieder gleich ganz ehrlich
die probieren wir heute nachzumachen und
ich bin mir sicher es wird keine leichte
Aufgabe legen wir los zu Hause
angekommen ich sag euch ehrlich ich habe
die halbe Packung schon in meinem Bauch
drin aber genauso wichtig wie die
Chicken Nuggets ist wahrscheinlich auch
die süß sauer Soße die wollen wir heute
auch nachmachen die Zutatenliste verrät
einiges unter anderem aprikosenmarkt
dies das Ananas Branntweinessig wir
kriegen das heute glaube ich alles
verdammt gut hin ich habe einige Rezepte
gefunden und ganz kurz vor habe ich mich
mal was sagen es kam ein zwei Kommentare
wegen Bad better von Joshua weiß man auf
weiß man ist ein riesen Inspiration für
mich und für diesen Kanal keine Frage
aber wir wollen nichts besser machen wir
wollen alles so nach und so original
getreue wie möglich hinbekommen und
dafür nehmen wir jetzt mal die Nuggets
genau unter die Lupe hier ist das Ding
es gab ja irgendwann mal dieses Skandal
das herausgefunden wurde das Chicken
Nuggets in verschiedenen Formen daher
kommt das liegt natürlich daran dass das
hier keine in der Natur vorkommende Form
ist sondern ich glaube sieben oder acht
verschiedene shapes gibt es die werden
wahrscheinlich dann mit irgendeinem
Aufsatz am Ende von diesen fertigen
System ausgeformt Adorno aber guckt euch
mal bitte die Oberfläche an wir haben
wirklich wie so kleine Gänge die sich
dann durch das Frittieren in dieser
Außenhülle gebildet haben wir sehen
außerdem wenn man genau hinschaut so
diese kleinen dunklen Spots oben drauf
und alles in allem ist das schon sehr
sehr charakteristischer Anblick der auf
jeden Fall sehr großen Hunger macht ein
weiterer Aspekt die faserigkeit die die
Nagels haben also es scheint zumindest
so als wären da noch einzelne Fasern
dabei und ich habe mich gefragt welches
Fleisch ist das weil darum
Krankenversicherung einige gemütten
laute Website ist es tatsächlich
hähnchenbrustfleisch zu 46 % als verrät
erstmal wie viel panadeanteil auch
eigentlich dabei ist aber die Webseite
hat uns auch einige weitere Zutaten
verraten zum Beispiel Maismehl noch vor
Weizenmehl das heißt wir arbeiten heute
mit zwei Mehlen Stärke bei zum Grieß
Weizen Gluten und immer wieder Sellerie
ich glaube das könnte so ein kleiner
lifehack sein dass wir heute mit
Sellerie arbeiten weil dieser typische
McDonald's Geruch hat kleine
Überschneidung mit Sellerie ich glaube
wir sind da was Großmutter auf der Spur
genug der Technik genug der Theorie
Videos wir sind unsere Hähnchenbrüste
wir haben uns überlegt wir bereiten die
auf zwei verschiedene Arten zu also wir
verarbeiten sie auf zwei verschiedene
Arten in die Nuggets Masse die wir
später brauchen einmal Wolfen wir Sie
durch einen feinen wolfaufsatz so dass
wir quasi dünne Fäden round chicken
bekommen das hat im Vorteil wir haben
noch eine Fahrsicherheit hoffentlich ein
weitere Idee der zur Häcksler da geben
wir auch ein Hähnchenbrust rein und
probieren die damit auch zu einer Masse
zu verbinden neben Hähnchenbrust sind
unsere einzigen Zutaten für die
Fleischmasse Zucker und Salz zwei Brüste
ziehen wir durch den Wolf zwei Brüste
püre auf jeden Fall gemahlene Sellerie
Samen und ich sage euch so viel wenn man
einmal eine Nase von nimmt hat wirklich
viel
schneiden wir Streifen aus unserer
Hähnchenbrust und wollten das ganze
unbekannte Anblick so sieht das ganze
jetzt aus wir geben ein bisschen Zucker
dran und ein bisschen Salz jetzt
vermengen wir das ganze wir müssen das
jetzt gleich einfrieren ne ganz genau da
müssen wir es erst Formen und dann
einfrieren erst einfrieren dann Formen
wir frieren sich komplett durch sondern
wir legen es in die Gefriertruhe für 10
bis 20 Minuten so dass einfach ein
bisschen fester wird und eine bessere
Masse mit der wir arbeiten können als
nächstes wieder Hähnchenbrust schneide
ich schon mal ein bisschen vor und gibt
die dann in mein verhexler ich sage euch
ehrlich vielleicht entsteht diese
Fahrsicherheit ja auch dadurch dass man
das ganze püriert und dann wenn es
gebacken wird wieder Fasern entstehen
ich bin ja wie gesagt auch kein
Lebensmitteltechniker oder so sondern
wir schmeißen einfach ein paar Methoden
die wir im Internet gefunden haben
zusammen überlegen mit unserem Verstand
was macht Sinn und probieren daraus die
original Methode zu finden los geht's
ich glaube das sieht richtig gut aus wir
haben zwei verschiedene Massen und ich
finde die schon jetzt ne hat das fast
ein bisschen was von dieser Phase ich
kalt ich glaube wir sind da was ganz
heiß mal auf der Spur die beiden gebe
ich jetzt zum Kühlen in die Gefriertruhe
und wir sehen uns gleich wieder guckt
euch das bitte einmal an direkt aus der
Tiefkühltruhe das hier püriert das hier
gewollt ich hätte es nicht gedacht ich
dachte das würde zu glatt werden zu
glatte Maße und hier hätte man eher
diese Farbe aber ist ja noch nicht
anderthalb Tage Abend als allererstes
machen wir erstmal den trocknet und den
flüssigen Teig denn es gibt gleich zwei
als erstes mache ich die trockenen Teile
die wir die melierungen hatten damit
dann später die flüssigkanade Tempura
auch haftet dafür nehmen wir Weizenmehl
und Maismehl im weißen Pfeffer dazu
weißer Pfeffer taucht irgendwie immer
und immer wieder auf etwas höre ich weiß
nicht warum es ausgerechnet einfach
günstiger schwarzer und Salz
einmal durchrühren und ich sage euch
ehrlich die gelbe Farbe von Mais wird
könnte eine der Komponenten sein die
hätte dieser Gold geben Nuggets Haare
schnuppern und jetzt zum flüssigen auch
hier starten wir mit Weizenmehl und
Maismehl es vor dem Minis Stärke als
nächstes Semmelbrösel warum falls auf
der Zutatenliste steht könnte mir
vorstellen dass die kleinen Semmelbrösel
und später diese dunklen Punkte in der
Panade geben dann noch ein bisschen
Backpulver weil der Teig arbeitet ja
auch also wir sehen auf der Oberfläche
was ich meinte diese kleinen
Tunnelsysteme wo sich irgendwie Lädchen
bilden könnte mir gut vorstellen das
Backpulver dafür Verantwortung Salz und
unsere Sellerie Samen den ganz ehrlich
ich glaube das Knollensellerie gemalt
noch mehr als Original rankommt aber
reine wirklich macht das auf jeden Fall
was ist sehr flüssiger Teig deshalb
geben wir ein bisschen Wasser dazu und
zwei Eier alles glatt
sehen auch hier wieder melden gelbe
Farbe ist jetzt schon vor dem Frittieren
auch da also dieses goldgelbe wird
mal bitte
oh ja
oder wirklich ja Digger oh das riecht
verdammt knapp Meckes bisschen aufräumen
Nuggets fragen und dann geht's rund
fangen wir jetzt an Nuggets zu formen
dafür mache ich mir meine Hände ein
bisschen nass und ich nehme direkt
erstmal ein bisschen was von dem
gemixten Form daraus einfach so diese
klassischen Form könnte jetzt schon
Nugget sein oder ich glaube da müssen
wir gar nicht viel was machen sondern
ich gebe dir direkt mal hier hinein ist
man denkt direkt man arbeiten mit einem
Teig wenn man so eine Masse hat und das
sieht so gut aus das sieht so richtig
aus vor allen Dingen irgendwas auch da
sind wir schon gar nicht schlecht
unterwegs meine lieblings Nuggets sind
ja eigentlich die diese Rechtecke
Rechtecke die perfekt
die Oberfläche ist so perfekt glatt wie
sie sein soll gleichzeitig haben wir
eine Fahrsicherheit so dann melieren wir
das ganze Gruber gelernt das darf auch
ruhig ein bisschen drin liegen bleiben
und wenn es ein bisschen drin lag holen
wir unsere Nuggets raus
wenn man mich fragen würde wie macht man
Chicken Nuggets ich hätte erstmal
gedacht man kann es gar nicht selbst
machen aber mit ein bisschen Recherche
und ein bisschen Nachdenken kriegt man
das gut hin jetzt nehmen wir einmal die
gewolfte Masse krass wie unterschiedlich
das rein optisch jetzt schon aussieht
nee sag auch hier Formen wir wieder mal
ein bisschen wie wir es uns vorstellen
einen ins Mehl wir sehen jetzt hier aus
dem Mehl herausholen verschwinden die
Unterschiede schon wieder ne also bleibt
spannend wie Nadia an die original
nuggetan die wiederhole den Prozess
jetzt mit dem restlichen schicken und
dann Frittieren hier wir probieren diese
Nacht zu machen es gibt so ein paar die
man ja immer wieder erkennt das Rechteck
das Rechteck genau der Kreis mit Zipfel
gehäuft und verhextet wir fangen mit den
hexelten an nehmen sie ziehen sie einmal
durch unseren flüssigteig und lassen
kurz abtropfen dann ab in die Fritteuse
und wir denken das Ganze einmal ab
170 Grad extra 170 Grad nicht 180 wo man
ja sonst häufig frittiert weil ich
glaube wir wollen so diese goldgelbe
habe mehr als so ein goldbraun und so
Chicken Nuggets Frittieren kümmern wir
uns um die süß-sauer Soße dafür gebe ich
ein bisschen Aprikosenkonfitüre bisschen
Pfirsich Knoblauchpulver etwas Sojasauce
Agavendicksaft Weißweinessig Senf und
Stärke in einem Topf zusammen über
leichter Hitze verrühren wir das Ganze
und ihr merkt schon guckt einfach mein
es wird vor unseren Augen zur McDonalds
süß sauer Soße naja wir pürieren das
noch mal für die stückigen Marmeladen
Konfitüren
fertig hättet ihr vorhin übrigens schon
auf meinem tiktok und Youtube schaut
sehen mein Traum
leute guckt euch bitte mal an wie unsere
Nuggets mittlerweile aussehen die sind
richtig ordentlich aufgegangen ja guck
mal bitte von unten oh shit vielleicht
ist so eine Gitter Friteuse auch nicht
unser richtiger coin zum Glück haben wir
noch ein paar die werden auch irgendwie
nicht so schnell Gold Brauen wie wir
gehofft haben
es dauert relativ lange aber man muss
Fehler machen um daraus zu lernen
geruchlich ist das richtig gut und von
der Faser her wow ohne Witz könnte von
Meckes sein das Ding ist die Panade ist
überhaupt nicht knusprig das heißt wir
müssen höher gehen mit der Temperatur
über eine Fritteuse immer auf 190 Grad
statt 170 lassen das auf Temperatur
kommt und dann sage ich natürlich
ehrlich habe ich große Hoffnung wir
haben jetzt die bestehenden Nuggets
einmal halbiert dünner ausgeformt und
jetzt geben wir sie hier noch einmal
rein in den Teig und direkt aus dem Teig
in das Fett weil vielleicht so ein
bisschen bewegen ja ihr merkt schon
Leute bei McDonald's die schäumen
wirklich keine keinen Aufwand und für
euch die perfekten Nuggets zu machen
ein bisschen aus wie Backfisch aber
irgendwie auch ein bisschen wie Nuggets
wir nehmen uns davon mal ein paar ich
sage euch so viel ich glaube die
Knusprigkeit haben wir auf jeden Fall
deutlich besser hinbekommen als beim
ersten Versuch das sind jetzt allerdings
ja nur die pürierten wir probieren das
ganze jetzt noch mal mit dem gewolften
und dann machen wir den test test
Freunde guckt euch das bitte einmal an
hier in der Mitte sind die originalen
Meckes Nuggets leider ist es nicht
schwer zu sagen dass sie die originalen
sind wir haben einfach auf der
Oberfläche nicht diese geschlossene
Oberfläche ist einfach nicht das Gleiche
aber es geht uns ja nicht nur um die
Optik sondern auch um den Geschmack um
die Haptik wie sieht das Ganze aus wie
fühlt sich an erstmal hier noch mal so
ein klassischer Meckes Chicken Nugget
wir sehen das hier da die sind nicht
mehr super super fresh ein bisschen
gekocht in der Zwischenzeit das hier ist
unsere Struktur das ist der Querschnitt
dann haben wir hier einmal die pürierten
Nuggets unsere eigenen boah das fühlt
sich richtig richtig gut an Zeit bei
side kaum Unterschiede zu erkennen die
haben wir zuletzt Frittieren das sind
die gewolften und auch hier sieht man
eigentlich nach dem Frittieren keine
großen Ziele mehr die Fahrsicherheit
bleibt also quasi gewahrt wenn wir das
hier so ein bisschen aufziehen ich habe
das Gefühl beide Wege führen zum Ziel so
von dem wie die sich reißen lassen jetzt
ne die hier gehen relativ easy
auseinander die hier den super easy
auseinander und die hier die gewolften
haben irgendwie obwohl die frischer sind
noch ein bisschen mehr Widerstand ich
glaube auch dass sie es eher die Art und
Weise wie Meckes das macht weil die
dadurch noch softer werden probieren wir
aber einfach mal wie das ganze jetzt
schmeckt selbstgemachte selbstgemachte
süß-sauer Soße wir probieren
Crunch ist da ich bin ganz ehrlich für
euch das Hähnchen innen drin ist einfach
nicht so saftig die werden original
Nuggets es schmeckt einfach anders es
wird irgendwie ein bisschen trocken
Panade Optik es geht alles in eine gute
Richtung aber ich würde sagen dass wir
nicht mal nah dran sind ganz ehrlich wie
bei Casey und es ist irgendwie übelst
schwer zu erklären woran es liegt und es
ist vor allem auch nicht besser hätte
ich gesagt okay unser Ergebnis hat
irgendwie schon auf eine Art und Weise
auch besser geschmeckt die Chicken
Nuggets sind einfach krass also wir
kommen da nicht dran ich hoffe trotzdem
dass das Video euch Spaß gemacht hat
schreibt gerne in die Kommentare ihr
wusstet auch in der Vergangenheit schon
den ein oder anderen Trick was wir noch
hätten besser machen können wie kommen
wir an dieses Ergebnis an wie kriegen
wir diese geschlossene wunderschöne
Panade eben na ja ohne Halt Millionen
oder Milliarden in die Entwicklung von
irgendwelchen Fast Food Instrumenten zu
stecken bis zum nächsten Video haut rein
danke fürs zuschauen und ciao